Prediction for biggest business loser in 2024
Is actually the German economy.
There's two big problems there.
First is that the loss of cheap Russian gas
has really cut the legs out from under
the German industrial model.
Their entire economy is based on industrial output,
and cheap Russian gas was sort of
at the foundation of that.
As you guys know,
someone blew up the North Stream pipeline.
I think that has really hurt the German economy.
And then second,
the German car industry has been massively impacted
by a sudden glut of cheap cars coming from China.
So if you look at the Chinese automotive industry,
it's really exploded in the last few years.
And auto exports is one of, you know,
is one of the biggest products that Germany
manufactures.
And with German cost going up
and Chinese cost coming down,
this is not a very good place for them to be.